people's health finances and daily lives
are significantly affected by our
ever-changing environment as a result
they are increasingly turning to their
financial service providers for
information about things like their
mortgage hours of operation credit card
payments other policies and 401ks using
online and phone support channels the
sudden unprecedented customer demand is
overwhelming customer support resources
in this video we will walk through a
contact center AI Rapid Response virtual
agent solution specifically designed for
financial service providers to help you
address immediate customer queries and
relieve pressure from your contact
centers let's take a look here's a
web-based experience let's say I'm a
mortgage customer looking to refinance
the conversational experience returns a
guidance and directs me to a link where
I can start the process now let's try
another example and pretend that we are
a banking customer I want to know the
best way to bank since I'm sheltering in
place and here I get more info on
drive-up teller windows and some things
like submitting a check or paying bills
online if you would like to customize
the solution with your own web UI to
match with your brand you can absolutely
do that here is an example let's say a
user is interested in finding the
closest open branches the chat part asks
for the user's location and then
responds back with the three closest
options to them these responses are
dynamic and are served off of a back-end
that queries Google Maps API and then
returns the closest locations along the
same line say a user is looking to know
their bank's hours of operation the
experience asked for the address and
returns back the closest bank with the
days and times the responses are coming
from the same agent it just has a custom
UI now if you have users calling in
through the phone you can easily assign
your phone number to the experience we
have one assigned here
let's call and find out about credit
card payments hello how can I help you I
will miss my credit card payments how
can you help if you want to formally
request that your credit card payment be
delayed for yourself or your business
then please enroll online for the
fastest service as you saw the open
source template is pre trained with
common financial services related
questions you may not hands and update
the experience as often as needed
through dialogue flow refer to the links
below for a quick guide to get started
you
[Music]